- [Mark] All right Chelsea.
Chelsea where are you from originally,
where did you grow up?
- [Chelsea] New York city.
- [Mark] And how was your childhood?
Grew up with both your parents?
- [Chelsea] Ya, my childhood was rough.
- [Mark] How is that?
- I grew up in the Bronx
and my parents were,
like, in the drug scheme.
Like selling drugs and stuff so,
and I got,
how do I say it,
I got raised in the trap house.
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- Like I kind of got raised
in like a trap house,
kind of where there was
a bunch of prostitutes
around all the time and my
dad and my mom and you know?
And they died when I was fourteen,
and then I started traveling.
- [Mark] How did your parents die?
- My mom got shot and my dad
blew up in a car accident.
- [Mark] Blew up a what?
- In a car accident.
- [Mark] So separate accidents?
And both when you were fourteen?
- Ya.
- [Mark] Oh I'm sorry
- But I have a twin sister
that is a trans man, so.
And
she's a trans man, and I was a girl.
You know what I mean?
And other wise from that
I was the black sheep.
- [Mark] Got it.
Any other craziness in your childhood?
- Ya, a lot. Like-
- [Mark] Like what?
- I had some issues with sexual situations
when I was thirteen.
I started prostitution and
then it lead into drugs.
- [Mark] At thirteen what? I'm sorry.
- I started, I prostituted and
did drugs for the first time.
- [Mark] Oh you did? At thirteen?
- Mm hm.
Ya because I watched my
mom do it so I thought
it would be okay.
And then I tried it, and
then I just kept doing it,
and then it lead to drugs, and then
it lead to me like
doing dumb stuff all the time.
Like trying to steal from
stores or just getting
in trouble and rebelling.
Otherwise that, nothing
really ever happened.
I was in a foster home/group home.
- [Mark] You were in a foster
home after you parents-
- Like foster homes and group homes.
- [Mark] Like after your
parents passed away?
- Ya I just rebelled really.
I really rebelled and then
I ran away from the group home
and I started hitchhiking
with my ex boyfriend
and, you know, my first
hitchhike was fourteen and
I got us a ride out into
(murmurs) and then from (murmurs)
the guy wanted us to
ride with him to Denver.
And then you know,
a lot of it I don't really remember.
- [Mark] So you've been
all over the country?
- Hm?
- [Mark] You've been all over the country?
- Ya I've been yo every
stare in the United States.
I've been to Alaska twice and I've been
through half of Mexico and
the whole country of Canada.
- [Mark] Oh really?
- Ya I rode freight trains and hitchhiked
pretty much my whole life.
- [Mark] Is that right?
- Ya it was really kinda hard.
Once I stopped riding I got stuck here,
it was kinda hard to communicate with the
human race again, cause I just had
three animals that rode freight
trains with me and stuff
and I was communicating with them
but that's a lot different.
You know?
So I kinda forgot how to
cope with other people.
- [Mark] What is your drug?
- Right now?
My drug of choice is crack,
it always will be crack
but I don't do crack anymore.
You know what I mean?
And right now I'm kind of smoking crystal.
- [Mark] Crystal meth?
- Like not at the very
moment exactly right now.
But, ya I do once in a while.
There has been times
where I have been on my
bike for like three days, just riding.
- [Mark] And not sleeping?
And crystal meth-
- No I don't think its
because of the crystal
I have a manic stages
too that I can't sleep
for like a week at a time or something.
But meth has a lot to do with it.
But um,
I just turned twenty nine yesterday and
I can say I still feel
like, endurance wise
or physical wise, I still feel
like I'm a teenager still.
- [Mark] Mm hm?
- Like I haven't felt any
different since I was like
sixteen, seventeen, you
know, so that works out.
- [Mark] And so do you have a tent now?
Or where do you sleep?
- Oh I don't,
I had a ten man tent and then
without my stuff in there.
Like my sleeping bag,
and I had a bed in there,
and a stove, and everything
I needed in there.
And somebody burnt my stuff down.
- [Mark] Ya that happens here a lot.
- Ya they burnt it to the ground
and then the next day they
wanted to try and apologize.
Like oh I'm sorry we didn't know,
we thought this was somebody else.
I'm like then maybe you
should have found out
who's it was before you burnt it down.
And now-
- [Mark] And what are
you doing for money now?
- Scavenging on the street,
looking for change or, you know.
I come up on bikes a lot
like in the garbage or
I trade my stuff here and there or
I come up on things in the street,
in the garbage and I trade.
But, never really money
more like the stuff I need.
- [Mark] Ya, do you ever
date guys for money?
- I have.
- [Mark] Ya.
Ya, but I don't anymore,
I mean I haven't done that
since I was twenty five.
But I don't really have
any passion for it either.
- [Mark] Do you ever talk to your brother?
- [Chelsea] Huh?
- [Chelsea] No, I don't
talk to any of my family.
I was really like the black sheep.
Like when I left that was the last time
I talked to any of them.
- [Mark] Do you have any friends
- [Chelsea] Ya I have a lot of friends.
- [Mark] Where are they?
- [Chelsea] Around.
Not like right here but
like from twelfth street,
I have friends over there,
I still have friends in new york actually.
I don't know.
I mean its kind of hard
to say do I have friends
because I make friends
everywhere I go because
I'm not a hard person to get along with.
- [Mark] Ya.
- [Chelsea] I mean I've
had a couple of friends
that were actually homophobic.
But for some reason they just accepted me.
If anyone else was like gay
or whatever he would be like
"faggot this" and "faggot that"
but this person like
always accepted me, so.
- [Mark] Do you think you
will be living like this
for the rest of your life?
- [Chelsea] No this isn't
something I wanna be doing.
Because I'm kinda already
feed up with this
because California probably
the worst I've ever been.
Like I've been to all these
places and nothing really
bad happened except for here.
I got my first charge in California here.
or my first bad jail charge here,
And then-
- [Mark] What was that for?
- Huh?
- I tried to steal two
phones out of target
and it didn't really work
out and I didn't really
know what lost prevention
was because we don't
really have that back home.
So they were trying to
disguise themselves and the
one in then middle was talking
about a faggot and something.
But the way they were walking
up on my I thought I was
going to get attacked
because I was real high and
kinda nervous and scared.
I kinda punched the guy
in the face I guess and
I went to jail and because
he didn't press charges
I got off that.
And then they dropped my
robbery charge down to a
grand theft on prison.
And then I did five
months in jail for that.
A month later I had standard
probation and then I did
seven more months because I
was trying to sell somebody
a dime bagger of meth in
the McDonald's parking lot
in Hollywood and I went back
to jail for seven more months.
And then when I got out
I was doing good and then
I was caught up with on of my
old friends and then I started
having sex with them again.
And then they failed to tell
me they had HIV and then I took
a test and then I realized that
I had HIV
and somebody who was
supposed to be my best friend
gave it to me
and they couldn't even
tell me they had it.
- [Mark] Sorry.
- Ya.
And then
I went though a lot in LA actually,
and I went through some shit
but I don't think I've been
put through as much shit as
I've been put through here.
You know, like even when I
was a kid I grew up rough
but I mean not like this.
- [Mark] Ya.
- Like I never imagined that
at twenty nine I would be
sitting in California homeless
and having HIV or nothing.
- [Mark] I think the homeless
communities on the west coast
are a little more extreme then they are-
- Ya.
- [Mark] Elsewhere.
- And out here is kinda
hard because me being white
and trans is a little bit harder because
a lot of the big population
is black or spanish.
So for some reason I feel like
because a lot of people
I hang around say its
because of my skin color.
White or whatever.
And I'm kind of picking it
up that maybe that's true
maybe it's not, you know,
but its like you know I've
had boyfriends here and
they didn't work out really.
And you know nothing has
really worked out for me
but just getting high
or I do have a lot of
friends though.
And you know I've also cut down a lot
like on smoking meth or whatever.
- [Mark] You're using less?
- Huh?
- Ya a lot less than I was.
Because I was smoking like two A-balls
within just the morning time.
You know, and that would
be everyday I would
smoke almost two A-balls every morning.
And then I would still smoke all day.
And now I'm only smoking
like twenty dollars worth
which is a tremendous amount of change.
- [Mark] Good for you.
- You know and
I'm trying to
day by day
I try to just sit around and make money
or make some change so I
can smoke some cigarettes.
I know its not cute to do
or its not the best thing to do
but its like a survival tactic.
Sometimes I boost from the
store, like if I'm hungry,
like if I desperately need
something from the store
and I don't have money for
it I'll go try and steal it.
And sometimes it doesn't work out.
So I have like eight court
dates in the next six months
- [Mark] Oh wow.
- Ya.
I feel like I got caught
stealing and caught another
citation or something.
But most of the time
its only for stuff that
I desperately need.
You know,
but, and I.
Its just one thing
everyday, something new.
- [Mark] All right, well
thank you so much for
talking to me.
- [Chelsea] Mm hm.
- [Mark] And good luck with everything.
- [Chelsea] Okay. Thanks
(sighs)